CBS News legal Ana's Rikki Kleeman joins
us at the table to discuss Rikki welcome
thank you so are you surprised by the
speed and these two articles
I think it's faster than the speed of
light and I think that one of the
reasons for that is that the conclusion
was made by the Democrats that the abuse
of power in and of itself represents a
clear and present danger to use their
phrase to the 2020 elections and to
national security so it had to be done
now they could not wait there was talk
of including obstruction of justice
regarding the Muller report but that's
not here bribery to bribery or extortion
bribery of course named in the
Constitution as to one of the high
crimes and misdemeanors bribery and
treason but ultimately abuse of power
was what we were looking at you had 17
witnesses who testified in the initial
hearings before the Intelligence
Committee and those 17 witnesses career
diplomats people who were not political
they really talked of a story that
reeked of abuse of power and then you
had the constitutional lawyers who were
saying if this is not impeachable I
don't know what is so choice narrow or
wide well narrow because of clear and
present danger if you go wide if you
were going to go back into the Muller
report and look at those enumerated acts
of corruption then you were going to get
into one of these contests that people
would be spitting at each other across
the aisle but they would have said this
has already been decided but this abuse
of power and the obstruction of Congress
because Congress was not permitted to
call witnesses and get documents from
the key people John Bolton Mike Pompeo
when you lay it out that way with the
witnesses that were called it sounds
like the Democrats have a very strong
case but the Republicans see it as you
know so very differently yes they do
here well one of the things is of course
the Democrats have a substantive case
and if you are a Democrat or you could
be an independent you could be swayed
they are giving
actual factual arguments the facts are
not disputed here the Republicans on the
other hand are giving you process argue
right but if this goes to the Senate
it's going to be run by the Republicans
yes and it is going to be run by Mitch
McConnell lest we forget the power to
impeach rests in the house the trial of
an impeachment rests in the Senate
although John Roberts the Chief Justice
gets to preside in the Senate what will
happen in the Senate will be up to Mitch
McConnell and if I were a betting woman
I would say what the Republicans are
going to try to do is to put Joe Biden
and his son hunter Biden on trial as
well as Ukraine and this completely
false absolutely debunked theory that it
was Ukraine that really messed up into
interfering in the 2016 elections we've
seen it at these hearings the
Republicans will not let this go what
you're basically saying it could end up
being a big mess or circus yes okay Rick
you clean them thank you when the
impeachment articles are revealed we'll
bring it to you on a CBS News special
report beginning around 9:00 a.m.
Eastern 8:00 central